good morning folks very good to see you
today
um just a brief run through
we're obviously coming to the close here
on everything that's going to be counted
in clark county
yesterday we saw a little over 1200
ballots go through
and as i have been mentioning for many
days
it's going to be a small group of
ballots that come in through the mail
now because the only thing we have left
now
are cures and the id required from
friday
those were manual emails that came in
and so it is taking some time to go
through those and identify exactly
which ballots should be counted because
the voter properly sent us by 5 pm on
friday a copy of their id
so we have staff continuing to go
through that
any increases in the mail from here on
out
will either be a cure from the voter or
one of those id required
again the deadline for cures is uh
thursday the 12th of november at 5 pm
the provisional update we are making
good progress on all of those records we
have received reports from the secretary
allowing us to go through our
provisional information
and make determinations those will be
loaded into the system
no later than thursday so i can't tell
you exactly how many right now
have been verified to be good to count
but we
are making good progress and we'll
definitely be able to bring those into
the system
today's the last day for us mail we
receive
seven so there are seven ballots that'll
come in from the u.s
mail this morning and that'll close out
all of the mail in clark county
with that i'll answer any questions that
you have
yes joe up to this point and especially
yesterday the secretary of state
and attorney general aaron ford both i
guess kind of had you back
talking about the integrity of the
election here in clark county how does
it feel to have the backing
of the state and having them going at
the back for clark county
we appreciate the support of the
secretary's office office obviously and
the attorney
general we work closely with the
secretary of state
the attorney general is very familiar
with our processes here
he is from clark county and he and i
have
known each other for some time it's not
uncommon for either
of those offices to reach out when they
have any questions related to what we do
we're always open and honest with what
we do
and i think that has resulted in the
support that we receive here in clark
county not because of me personally
but because of what we do here working
with our da and all the people that make
sure that things are run correctly in
clark county
so i'm not surprised that they support
us they're very aware of what we do
and we're glad that we do have their
support
a quick clarification on the agilis
counting i believe you said yesterday
that
30 of ballots that went through the
agilities were automatically
verified and 70 percent before it had to
go through and be manually verified
that's in the ballpark right
yes um of that 70 that had to be
manually verified
well what percentage of those were
ultimately rejected through the manual
process
all of our information is posted on the
website
so those would be cures there are other
reasons why ballots could go through and
be
manually verified however once they go
to the counting board
they also get spoiled because voters
inadvertently put two ballots into one
envelope in which case we don't know
which voters signed for that ballot so
neither one of them are good
people identify their ballot they don't
read the instructions
and try to make a correction and maybe
initial on the ballot
statute very clearly states that we
cannot count those ballots so
um yeah that those numbers are publicly
reported
i don't have them off the top of my head
joe how many cases of alleged voter
fraud
were passed on to the secretary of
state's office i believe my pio has that
information and it'd be better if he
shared that with you there's a million
things going on here related to the
count and i don't want to confuse those
numbers
however he does have that information
and i believe shared that yesterday
and can you explain the guidelines for
military voters and why technically they
do not have to live here why they vote
well obviously they're serving the
country um so they're not here in nevada
however they do declare clark county as
their home residents and so that makes
them eligible to vote
even retirees have the ability to live
somewhere else but still claim nevada if
they at one point in time served
in clark county so there are a large
number of veterans who claim clark
county as their home residents and so
they are eligible to vote and we do
process their ballots
do you any requests yet
no they can't make that request until
after the canvas
after the canvas is complete they need
to make that request within three days
and then
at the same time uh pay the fee
uh for us to recount those ballots so
we i don't have any uh i have some
inquiries about exactly how the process
works yet but we don't have any yet
because they're not eligible to put
those in until after the canvas is
complete which is monday the 16th
joe monday the 16th is that could not be
changed
or delayed is that correct that would
have to take some type of court order in
order for something like that to happen
it's
defined in ab4 which was passed in the
special
legislative session i wanted to follow
up if i can on the
question about complaints i know we we
caught up as of yesterday
i think maybe the question would be have
there been any new
complaints submitted that you may have
passed up to the secretaries
not that i'm aware of but again i would
give that to my pio's office they're
doing an excellent job of helping me to
keep all of this straight
and also my civil d.a who's been doing
an excellent job
my representative down there is
extraordinary as well
i'm very fortunate and blessed to work
with so many talented people who keep me
out of hot water
um and they are definitely a group that
has been working tremendously hard to
keep all of these
legal challenges in play and make sure
that we're complying according to what's
required
by the law so i i would ask you to get
with a pio
just being six days out from the final
count at this point
tell me a little bit about your
confidence level that every vote will be
counted
very high we've been working hard ever
since we started to make sure
that's exactly why um i've been
confident in coming out here and
communicating to you
we tried very hard as a department to
make sure that we're
providing information that answers the
questions that the general public has
so we're very very confident that
everything that we put through
will be qualified voters
mr gloria procedural question on
thursday
you'll be done do you anticipate having
a
uh anything like this to say so
or um how will that
be i don't think so it'll be very late
at night when we're done
um because the deadline is at five
o'clock
and so there'll be a mad rush to make
sure that anybody that has cured by five
o'clock we've got to go
pull those ballots we've got to make
sure that they get sent to the
accounting board to be quickly
separated identify those ballots
that are good to be counted because they
haven't been identified or anything
along those lines
and then work to get those in and these
electronic provisionals that are going
in on thursday that's
that's a considerable amount of work
that needs to be done too so
we may be working late into the night on
thursday because the statutory we have
to be done by that date and there's no
moving that deadline
should we maybe anticipate seeing you
friday morning at this time oh
absolutely
at this current time i work for people
too so if they tell me i have to do it
at midnight then we'll be here at
midnight
joe is the number of uh still under 2000
yes it is
you've talked in the past about how
important transparency and trust in the
process
and in the system is for you but for
those people who are
out in the community right wrong or
indifferent in their opinions that they
contend
they don't trust the process and they
think something nefarious is going on
what do you say to those people out
there who are
saying all of that i would say that i
would ask the general public to take
into consideration where you're getting
your information because unfortunately
there are groups out there who are
working
to discredit our office there are
communications going out to voters that
don't come from my office
that don't come from the secretary of
state trying to pass out false
information such as that their
provisional ballot only has a
presidential race on it which is not
true
we change that in ab345 in the 2019
legislative session all provisionals are
a full ballot for all voters
regardless of the provisional that's
provided they're calling out to
let voters know that their vote didn't
count because it was provisional they're
calling out to let voters know that
their vote didn't count
because it's not showing vote history
all of the things that i've tried to
clarify in these press conferences
are being contradicted by groups who are
calling and trying to confuse voters so
the only true source of information is
the secretary of state and clark county
we are the only ones who can give you
accurate information as to how you voted
how we have it registered and whether
it's eligible to be counted
that's pretty much all i have to say
there
you all have a great day